un peu la corriger un truc sur l'iPhone
qui était pas terrible regardez je vous
montre avec l'arrivée d'iOS 16 vous
pouvez avoir directement le pourcentage
de batterie sur votre iPhone pour venir
l'activer c'est facile vous allez dans
réglage vous allez dans batterie et vous
cliquez sur pourcentage de la batterie
sauf que avant cette mise à jour de Ios
16.1 que je vous invite vraiment
d'ailleurs à bien faire vous voyez votre
batterie pleine tout le temps et vous
aviez le pourcentage dessus des fois il
me restait 20 % et pour autant j'ai pas
l'impression qu'elle était pleine donc
là ils sont venus le corriger on voit le
niveau de décharge de la batterie et en
plus de ça vous avez le pourcentage
restant je trouve ça vachement bien donc
je vous invite vraiment si c'est pas
déjà le cas avenir faire votre mise à
jour vers iOS 16.1 d'autant plus que ça
offre cette fonctionnalité a beaucoup
plus d'iPhone que par le passé